i have a new podcast that i'm doing once
a month where i sit down with two video
game writers each month to talk and talk
to them about about video game writing
it was in part because i wanted to as
soon as i started video game writing
which you know i'm in my second year now
and i still feel like i don't know
anything or um i also repeatedly i'm
learning how different other studios
operate
so i was like look i know all these
people i think that is the single best
thing about me having a youtube channel
is that i know a lot of people and can
get access to people and it's not just a
person
sitting in a computer yelling about
video games it's it's people who work on
video games yelling about video games um
so i was like what if i just sit down
with different writers every month and
i'm trying really hard to
get somebody um who's worked on
localization at fromsoft because i was
like that's a facet of writing i don't
know anything about um that i feel like
they'll be cautious talking about but i
was like i don't i know that it's really
important and i know that um the guy
who's probably best known for working on
uh localization for from games has
written a lot of lines himself and
that's part of that job it's like i just
don't know so little about it it's a
massive part of it like the amount of
adjustments and tweaking it's
fascinating to be on the dev side of
that into other languages like the
number of conversations i've had to have
with people about kind of like you know
a particularly english language joke
yeah one of our games and then kind of
working it through and making
suggestions of how to make that funny in
french or whatever totally it's really
it's fascinating yeah it's way harder
than people think that's why it's not
called translation it's called
localization it's a process and i was
like i'd really love to talk because
that's that's cool still kind of writing
i'd just love to talk to somebody about
so yeah i have some really cool
you have like you have like different
guests per two different guests every
time um and the biggest struggle is that
every time that i'm trying to do it i'm
trying to piece together people that i
think would also get along who don't
necessarily like a dinner party it is it
totally is i'm like oh but i want this
person to make this person feel
comfortable and like it's it's been hard
but
yeah i just uh i just sit down and talk
to different video game writers every
month second monday of every month it's
going to publish and i keep having
people like how do you have time to do
these podcasts it's like it just takes
an hour to record that's it i just hit
record for an hour and then i send it
off to somebody else to edit and i'd
have these conversations with people by
choice anyway so what i'm doing is just
sharing it with everybody else so that
i'm just not hoarding all the knowledge
it i mean
but you also do a lot it's kind of like
i mean sure i do a lot out there and
have a full-time job at the same time
yes but recording podcasts it's not
nothing not that difficult um which
directly ties into the situation it's
very difficult
that's why you do it every week
hi everyone audio cut out probably talks
over you there my audience no no you're
fine uh welcome to play watch listen
it's just me and mike today because we
weren't even going to do an episode this
week we're just going to skip doing this
week but then the biggest video game
news of probably the last 10 years
dropped and i was like okay i really
want to talk about this i feel like we
should talk about it austin does know
that we're doing it um but we're not
sure if he'll drop in or not he might
or otherwise maybe the first episode he
misses but yeah very impromptu i was
just like maybe two hours ago i was like
mike i just want to talk about it so
let's do it
um so here we are talking about
i was trying to come up with a
banjo-kazooie coming to switch tomorrow
yeah finals i'm excited it's finally
it's finally here again switch
um no so of course if you somehow missed
again the biggest gaming news of the
decade microsoft
is buying you can't technically say
bought at this point is in the process
of buying
activision blizzard um in every single
studio that they have under their wing
for 68.5
billion dollars i keep wanting to say
million and then i wrote i accidentally
said a million in conversation the other
day and was laughed out of the room i
just did what very mean about that today
it's not fair i just made a comment
where i was like i just feel like they
should have rounded up and gone for the
69 just to commit to the meme and
somebody was like a lot of that that
would be like an extra 300 million
dollars and i was like
oh you're right oh
that's so much [ __ ] money jesus
christ these numbers my kenny said no
it's like they are ridiculous it's it's
absurd and like it's crazy that it even
it even sorry 68.7 billion is what it is
even i was still off um
it is
an unthinkably large amount of money and
even more than they bought before which
was already an unthinkably large amount
of money what was bethesda
15
let me check how much did buy bethesda
four
7.5 for zennimax
five seven 77.5
five billion this is 16 times point
seven
billion dollars
um mike what were your what were your
reactions to this how did you feel about
it
i was shocked like genuinely like
shocked like usually with these things
not to be that prick but usually with
these things you've already heard about
it or there's like [ __ ] sure the fact
that this didn't sweep like some
mumblings or just like not even
necessarily like a public league but you
hear things you hear the rumblings or or
you at least hear like something massive
is happening at 10 a.m or something like
some there is some kind of conversation
and this one genuinely i had no
knowledge of i none of the people who
normally tell whisper me news none of
them did um so this i guess it was
i don't know i guess it was tighter than
the usual but i guess it is such a
massive topic that yeah it's it was it
was
surprising like kind of shocking and
kind of
it's one of those things that
immediately you just want to unpack
this is what we're doing here right like
just kind of step through and kind of
figure out what the hell just happened
how about you was it the same for you
was it just a similar work up to it
right it was already the twit the
internet i happened to be awake at 5am
and it was published at 5 35 a.m and uh
when i saw it
i was just sitting
i i think i was having breakfast and i
was just looked at my phone and i
audibly alone in my apartment went
what
i was just so shocked
um
just myself just lit up with like
everyone wanting yeah just yeah so so so
unexpected um would never have guessed
this would never have been on my bingo
card so that's obviously the immediate
reaction and then my my follow-up
immediate thing that came to mind is
obviously the situation with the
treatment of employees at activision
blizzard and uh the
pretty much objectively poor leadership
of bobby kotec not a fan um and i was
like that's a hot take you do you want
to commit to that take that spicy i am i
had someone else watching me i have had
somebody like you have said some pretty
nasty things about bobby kotec you work
in the games initially you should be
careful and i was like [ __ ] bobby kotex
i don't care if somebody comes to my job
because i said [ __ ] bobby kotik take my
job i don't need it
he's my least favorite soon to be fired
ceo in the game i sure hope so so that
was my first thing my first first
reaction was what does this mean for the
employees at activision blizzard does
this mean better treatment um phil
spencer now being promoted i guess is a
shadow part of the article that came out
to ceo of microsoft gaming i don't even
know if that division uh officially
existed prior to this it might be to
kind of sit activision underneath it's
probably just kind of an org
reorganization yeah so phil seems like a
great guy um every interaction i've had
with phil he's been lovely and i i feel
like he does genuinely care about people
so that seems like a massive positive
but it's also like you know like you
said you just want to unpack it first up
like what does this mean for the
lawsuits
is that microsoft spurred in now or is
that separate
ultimately yeah i mean i assume they
were against the company well i don't
know enough if they were if they were
against individuals but i doubt they
were against individuals because you
would normally make a suit against the
company
so i guess yeah that would be their
burden
um
that the company would have been cheaper
because of the pending lawsuits so
that's the that's yes that is the that
is the ungenerous read is this was an
excellent time on a purely capitalistic
level to purchase activision because
they they were doing very badly
well
comparatively
their shares were in a in a low place so
yeah it was a bit of a bargain yeah
ridiculously sounds to call this a
bargain but i i know but it i mean again
that's why it's even comprehensible
maybe if that this
they weren't in the situation they're in
where it's also like no one talks about
this i feel like blizzard hasn't
actually released a game
since overwatch
they've released expansions and dlcs and
i think maybe like hearthstone was
earlier right yeah
overwatch is their last actual game
release unless there's something very
recent that i'm forgetting um so
blizzard's not really putting games out
um
the activision branch
i mean there are many franchises that
i'm like oh maybe we bring back
prototype i don't know how many people
are asking for that but i certainly am
i
would love to see more prototype but um
and then obviously call of duty um is
kind of evolving in the space that it's
in now obviously with warzone is still
pretty popular um
it's still one of the biggest franchises
of all time no matter how you chalk it
up it is one of the biggest franchises
of the year even if you're like yeah you
grow stupid stagnant it's still a dragon
sorry still huge it's it's still big in
a way that most video games can't even
imagine yeah like it's it's on a
different level i think that's the
presumably that's where most of the
value of a company like that's what
makes activision worth
10 times from what you said of of of
what bethesda is is yes it's these
franchises like
like
uh morrowind's awesome like wolfenstein
is like the the newest what the newer
ones i think are absolutely fantastic
but those are video games for video game
players they're very successful within
that realm
call of duty is pop culture
different
yeah candy of course candy crush yeah of
course i'm forgetting how enormous that
side of the business is
yeah like there's all of these things
that are like
stuff that your
grandparent who's never played video
games has heard of culturally and is
aware of like it's a different tier of
kind of of success and that's that's
presumably yeah that's where a lot of
that value is kind of coming from um in
terms of to answer your question i
should just go back to of what this
means for staff treatment yes i imagine
microsoft is obviously very incentivized
to make that conversation into a
positive one so microsoft are famously
in you know respected for their
treatment of staff generally so i worked
there about 10 years ago was when i just
started out in the industry i worked for
microsoft not in a full-time capacity
but i did work for them um
and i was treated very well they were
very kind to me um i think spencer
himself has like said that they've not
got the perfect track record and it's
unlikely the company of any size would
but they are they have a reputation and
for being good and they would want to
maintain that site i suspect in terms of
people who are working at activision
this is probably going to improve your
situation like i would assume that
there'd be some some a lot of hr stuff a
lot of like support stuff that will
actually kind of improve as a result of
this well because your companies are
being run by the same person who was
being run yeah
the
the thing about so you know i i think
there are a number of things about
activision blizzard structurally that i
feel like i dislike and one of them is
the pay disparity between bobby kotek
their ceo and the average employee so
technically um on average an activision
employee is paid a bit more
than
the rest of the industry uh however
compared to the disparity versus what
their uh executives are earning it is
one of the biggest gaps in the industry
and by a disgusting margin it's so big
um well his his parachute for have you
you've seen that have you seen that
spreadsheet of the different ways bobby
cote could leave the company and the
amount of money he would get paid down
that is a huge part of this it's a
bummer is that like no matter even that
number is obscenely have you seen the
chart shall i send it to you yeah no i
haven't seen that i could maybe look it
up what is it like is it is something he
made
something he made yeah he put it up with
like a smirking emoji
no
someone made it on twitter or something
yeah or someone found i'm just gonna pop
it up over to you because uh in any case
it sounds like he will be out once the
deal closes but yes he's probably going
to get a lot of money um and that's a
thing of 170 million dollars
this is fine
um it's so another thing that that has
been a little bit troublesome about how
activision blizzard have been operating
is a lot of layoffs very consistently a
large amount of layoffs and this is
something that usually happens with
mergers that is um i would consider to
be a downside is that there will be
layoffs but i think their layoffs are
most likely to be
if they do have them as part of the
merger which again i think they probably
will other than bobby um
it's probably
like people in accounting in hr and i
think i still think that sucks that's
still a bummer um i don't want anybody
to get laid off but the benefit is
obviously the company clearly needs a
culture restructure and and i you know
again my head first when i saw this news
was not to the console wars that have
flooded the internet it was immediately
like i hope that this is good for those
people um that would be real nice
opening this link you've sent here a
purpose of nothing here's how much
activision blizzard has to pay kotec if
he is terminated as a result the change
of control of the company per his
employee agreement oh
so this was public maybe
i think this was made public by i think
as part of you know a shareholder's
report or something at some point oh wow
this is really interesting oh my god the
total the the last i thought this would
be the kind of thing you'd be into yeah
it's uh jesus that's a lot of money so a
termination by activation blizzard
without cause or termination by employee
for good reason following a change of
control is probably what the term is
which would be a total of 292 million
dollars
also add to that the shares that you
would own the company that would be sold
off at the same time so there would be
there's actually a lot more money as
well just on that kind of side of it so
yes he will
he will make more money than
the town you live in we'll see in a
lifetime yeah
that's an exaggeration
yeah i live in la okay just yeah i was
gonna say like a great example
but everywhere else
the audience member who lives in a town
of 50 people the city i was born in
probably not competing with bobby
cotick's salary shout out to cairns
australia so yeah that was that was
definitely my first thought is like what
does that mean um
and yes it does seem like you know while
they didn't explicitly state it probably
because they can't yet that he he will
be gone and hopefully far away from the
games industry um
says uh this is uh business insider has
said that sources said that both
microsoft and activision have agreed
that kotek will depart once the deal
closes which could take anywhere from 12
to 18 months um but yeah they i i the
press release did say bobby kotek will
continue to serve as ceo of activision
blizzard but i feel like that said just
for now
yeah it's very hard to imagine
him not being uh out of the picture at
that point it would be such a bad just
pr for microsoft too i don't feel like
you want to take a company and not take
that and you know the part where it
became really negative was when it came
out that he had known for years about
claims of sexual harassment and rape and
didn't do anything about it um pretty
serious stuff so then very seriously the
that that again was my first talking
point the second thing that i feel like
a lot of people are talking about that i
i wanted to ask uh your input on mike is
the suggestion that this is um
some kind of monopoly that's being
created and if this could go against
trade laws
oh well that that i'm out of my depth
and i'm due to what is
it certainly puts a lot of power in one
place i'll say that like i don't
i
you know as discussed on last episode
like british liberal law is very strict
so i would never accuse any involved
company of a crime
but um no i i think i i don't know
enough about monopoly laws to having
have a coherent position well but yeah
it definitely it adjusts power and it
centralizes power on a specific platform
which is really interesting and
reminds reminds you of like different
points in history where that has
happened so and has happened you know
with microsoft in the past uh a couple
points in time so it's interesting
i don't i don't know enough about the
legality to put it what's your answer to
that question i mean same obviously i'm
not a lawyer it's not a thing that i'm
an expert in but i feel like um
this is not something that i think is a
realistic concern just because it's not
quite enough uh they still have so many
competitors especially when you consider
like the existence of even amazon and
apple you know the ones that we don't
look at as core to the console
gaming market um it's just too big and
it's still they're still not as big as
tencent
so if it hasn't happened
right who everybody ignores um microsoft
is still technically not as big as sony
in terms of of gaming either even with
this acquisition um is that right i know
that yeah i mean
i guess
i ha i just based on those numbers i
guess someone like we could get more
information about that over the coming
days of somebody saying that it's been
pushed above but um it doesn't appear to
have been i don't believe that this is
making them overtake 10 cents the
revenue isn't isn't
although i can believe that i meant that
i meant the sony thing that was yeah i
don't think so
but um i could change i don't know
but also i think people are i think to
an extent
and this is true of us developers as
well like
i think you know console is a subsection
of the gaming industry and it's actually
like a smaller one compared to yeah
mobile desktop
various other stuff like we're not well
i think console's still bigger than
desktop
yes i think that that console gaming is
still bigger than pc gaming
um probably wrong man but i think like
by a surprising amount but that mobile
gaming is the juggernaut mobile dwarves
buy a lot which 10 cent is all up in and
i think that uh king outside of
obviously microsoft's interest in um
cloud streaming
uh is
you know the biggest acquisition for
them in terms of mobile because nobody
else is really involved in that market
and i've been saying this for a while i
don't know if i've ever said it on play
watch listen but i very firmly believe
that you should expect every single one
of your favorite franchises to end up on
mobile
every single year everyone from
everything they're not all ready and so
they aren't already
expect that to happen sooner rather than
later and i think it was like looking
into take two's finances that really
tipped me off to that but i was like oh
everyone is going to do this um you
should expect everything on mobile
what's interesting i think in a lot of
cases a lot of the ip holders of the big
ip
um
they're actually going about it in such
a way where they're kind of
creating little enclaves like they to an
extent
yes 100
there's call of duty on mobile but if
you're a call of duty console player
activision probably historically has
been trying to prevent you from knowing
or caring about that like obviously if
you're super into it and you're looking
all the press releases and stuff you're
going to see it but the average kind of
player the kind of player who wouldn't
watch a show like this
is not actually necessarily aware of
where they're at and you actually see
and it is huge
it's not mobile this massive
yeah but you're right i don't see it
advertised to me
because it would for you it would
because their assumption i think it's an
accurate assumption would be that to the
average console player it being a mobile
game would actually devalue the brand to
them a little bit
and it's an interesting and and likewise
to that mobile audience
they're going to go to that audience and
produce a version of the game that's
tailored to that audience and they
probably don't want that audience to
think oh this must be a hardcore console
game that's actually going to work
against their interests
it's it's there's actually a splitting
whereas we used to be in a you know in a
world with kind of this mono culture
where
a franchise was targeted a specific
audience now because everyone's so much
more fractured you get a franchise or an
ip and then you've got these tons of
things all branching off specifically
tailored to different people if you look
at like i mean marvel's a good example
right like
spider-man is there for your hardcore
console gamer um you've got the what's
the name of the the x-com studios game
that's coming up
marvel xcode
was called let me let's get dark crystal
[Music]
midnight suns midnight sun yeah
i would not have remembered that you're
fine
but that one like that's you know that's
that's yeah that's your kind of nerdier
hardcore audience being targeted and
then you've got all of these mobile
games which
you know maybe you've seen an ad for for
you on youtube and never seen but those
games are making phenomenal money so
every single kind of area of the
audience is being kind of catered to
with one you know spider-man camera you
don't think that there is um
any reason for
the current
console
focus side of it like i don't know how
to phrase this question you don't think
there's any reason that they would want
to push me to mobile
like do you think that there is a reason
that they could be like okay well you
have this amount of time in your day
where you are not playing on your
console because you're not at home we
want to get any any period in between
where you are still spending money so we
want to port you over to mobile because
my guess is that that is coming that
maybe we're not there right now and i
think i think you raise a great point
that it could be because to me it would
devalue something obviously you know
that don't you guys have phones thing
from blizzcon like i feel like it's a
great example yeah the core gaming
market has been pretty hostile an
additional game i have no idea i get why
the audience reacted yeah totally i like
they react to that i don't want you know
especially when you're excited about
something and you get that from a
franchise and actually i actually think
that game's pretty good um but
outside of that you know it's something
that usually you're just not not
interested in i it's hard to get me to
play a mobile game but i do feel like
the wave is coming of of them being like
these are good enough we want to get you
over there so that we can take away that
screen time that you're spending on
twitter and instagram see it happening
if there's screen time that's that's
giving i don't know if if uh publishers
have access to the data but like the
amount of time people do spend on their
phones and they're like why aren't you
spending that playing video games we
need to monetize your screen i feel like
that wave is coming
yeah i can't it'll
but it but even then i bet it'll be
something that is tailored to your
hardcore so it will be more the kind of
the second screen experience that's kind
of showing you your stats on the the
multiplayer game you just played or
allowing you you know information or
like a deep dive on something i do
already trying to put you to a match
three it'll be trying to put you in
you know some some extension that's
tailored to you rather than
you know you can see that with the mega
ip so things like marvel where there are
like 20 different mobile games and each
of them is kind of playing to a
different crowd or a different genre
um i think that's yeah that's where
these things are going for sure yeah i
mean this is just such a huge win for
for microsoft in that regard it's got to
be the candy crush part of it it's
probably going to be worth so much money
that yeah we're not talking about well
candy crush like no it's a big deal and
the numbers on candy crush is still
right oh terrifying yeah absolutely it's
tremendous so
yeah i mean i forgot what we were even
talking about prior to this but um
where you know the monopoly stuff is
concerned i think that like
i don't love any one
uh platform holder owning
everybody um
and obviously we're not there yet we're
very far away from that but there's
something about just just in general
having one company own everything is not
generally very good for competition and
i hope that this doesn't you know create
a ripple effect of more of this
happening i feel like my reaction to um
the studio like double fine being bought
was like amazing i love double phone
they're small now they have more support
good for them that's awesome congrats
like congratulations to microsoft double
fines incredible where when it's
activision blizzard it's more of a
again i hope those employees benefit
from this but otherwise like i'm not
like massively concerned but it's not
it's not something that i think that is
generally good for um
players at a large scale if this is
something that continues to happen at
microsoft keep buying people up
if if it becomes a standard like it's
also for like for the little fish like
me it's interesting because it does
we benefit greatly from the comp
competitive nature of the consoles and
the fact that they are fighting for the
same games all that you've got so so
someone like me in most cases my games
are going to release on more than one
platform um if they have if there's a
game that hasn't then there's a good
financial reason for that um but usually
i'll release someone's platforms so i
benefit from an ecosystem which is
trying its hardest to kind of
appease frankly people that matter you
know financially successful games really
great example of this is like
cross-platform play which was nowhere
and was banned on most of the platforms
and was something that a lot of indie
developers were kind of pushing for and
wanting to do cross-platform kind of
supporting their games
and were laughed out of a lot of rooms
because
you know this isn't something that
serves us why would we want to encourage
people to to buy our gay buy a game on
another person's console you know who
how does this help and then you have
something like fortnight come along that
suddenly incentivizes like no we need we
need players to be able to migrate over
to our platform to play this game that
they're already playing uh so therefore
suddenly those floodgates open in a
world where
you know the console is also the console
company is also producing all of the
content for the console you don't have
that back and forth you don't have those
kind of negotiations that trickle down
you know you don't have people trying to
find business models to support
multi-platform games or support kind of
encouraging multi-platform games over if
a multi-platform game
goes from being you know the kind of
thing like call of duty that will make
everyone involved a ridiculous amount of
money to a multi-platform game being the
kind of thing i would make where
everyone does okay but like you know
it's it's a multitude smaller
that becomes that gives me less room to
negotiate in those meetings and that's
potentially a knock-on there's i think
there's benefits which we can get to in
a second but like there's that's the
kind of there's a negative there in
terms of uh
essentially i'm this is what happens
when it's just you and me i become
someone who's arguing for the free
market which is
biggest
like there's there's there's something
to be said for a marketplace where
uh
other people with bigger pockets are
trying to achieve the same business
models that i'm trying to achieve i can
get kind of i can get benefits from that
i can get kind of treated better as a
result of that i guess there's also a
world where if you own um you know all
of the studios that that come under um
just my is my curious visions also part
of this
i lose track i think vicarious presence
is
are they owned by activision they are
activision yep
they are um so you've also got like you
know some of their smaller studios like
vicarious visions and toys for bob that
have shown that they can work on
different things and you could make a
case for instead of
you know going to a bethel games and
funding um an indie game or like how the
id xbox program is has traditionally
functioned where i imagine that somebody
pitches something to the id xbox team
yeah you go in with something and say
why wouldn't you go to the studio you
already own um and this obviously is
complete speculation but in theory you
know that having more and more and more
studios
you would be incentivized if you're
microsoft to to lean more heavily on the
studios you own than taking games
from other companies outside um you feel
like that is a fair assessment or do you
think that the they will still
incentivize
i mean you can even see that within
activision so activision used to publish
third-party games yeah like they you
they've activation turned over the last
someone was pointing this out to me the
other day like activision 10 years ago
were releasing games made by developers
who were external and they kind of
consolidated everything within them
sakura was surprising because uh it was
it was a departure for activation you're
right that was that wasn't external
everyone was like whoa oh i remember
they used to do that
so does that mean microsoft on seca
right now i guess
well they would own publishing rights
but yeah it's um so so so yes that's
definitely a thing but it also is part
of a much bigger issue which is or a
much bigger kind of
push that's happening with microsoft is
there in the con the rolling content
business now so they need a lot of it
they need a lot of games full stop you
need they need they need a bunch of
stuff to get you to keep on hold of your
game pass right like that's the that's
the business model now this is not no
it's a whole new game that's why like
the console aspect of it especially
i mean it's of zero interest to me
anyway uh one of my colleagues tweeted
um today something that was like
like he was being added about it he was
like do you think that because some of
my friends work at bethesda that we're
not friends anymore we all like each
other's names
[Music]
i don't think the audience at large
understands that like you will be at an
industry event
and the the famous senior people at each
of these console platforms that you're
fighting for are sat at a table laughing
and drinking having a great time we all
just really like video games
professionals yeah
um so it's it's it's it's not there's no
it's yes of course there's there's um
there's there's business incentives and
business reasons to kind of that you
would have partnerships yeah but i don't
feel like this is uh but everyone gets
on people official spencer is gonna
shake the hand
of of jim ryan if he sees him in the
corner 100 an event yeah that's that's
just inevitable that's that's phil and
herman are really nice dudes who like it
just if they don't think that way and my
point to that is like even outside of
that outside of that fabricated drama
that's really coming from audiences who
admittedly have been funded to have a
tremendous amount of loyalty uh because
it's interesting and told by marketing
teams yeah for twenty loyalty please i
say in my playstation shirt
um that
i don't think that microsoft is playing
that game they are doing something very
different which of course is uh game
pass as a service is not about consoles
it is about that service it's on pc i
use it on my pc more than i use it on my
xbox at this point yeah um
they are competing with what apple is
going to do next and what amazon is
going to do next in a different way um
that i don't i don't think it's it's
about that and they did uh i think
released the stats yesterday too that
that game pass now has 25 million
subscribers
that's a lot of money that was up from
18 million in january last year so it is
growing pretty significantly um and they
do have a hell of a lot of video games
and of course in this
press release said that um you know
they'll be bringing activision games to
game pass as well of course of course um
yeah there are already
20 bethesda games dishonored doom elder
scrolls fallout wolfenstein all of which
you know are huge franchises that i love
to bids
um
so that's they have to keep that rolling
yes because those games those bethesda
games awesome brilliant games
but you've played them yeah if you're
and you've seen them and they're there
and that's that's the interesting
challenge here is is the business like
the way uh the way these cons both both
xbox and sony used to be and the way
sony still is for the moment um is is
very much around this kind of hit driven
you know you make a god of war which
brings in an audience and then you keep
them around and you know that you're
under their tv at that point so then as
long as you ship something really cool
every six months or so you're gonna be
fine and i really hope that sony sticks
to that like of all the people being
like what if sony you know so you should
come back and do this and i'm like
as a player
it's completely removed as a
player
um i hope that sony doesn't i think that
that playstation right now releases so
many just incredibly high quality games
they're just so good and i think that
that can happen
when
you're
you're you're doing the exact model that
you suggested there where it's about
like getting people onto the playstation
platform and i think the minute that it
becomes about like this purchasing war
of trying to get more and more and more
than sony's goals would change and we
would potentially lose these like
incredibly high quality blockbuster
titles that i think are some of the best
games i've ever played i i hope that
sony continues to do exactly what they
are doing because i'm so glad that
they're doing what they do in the
industry as a player
and selfishly as a business owner i
really hope they do too yeah because
it'll be great for me um and this is
this is the other this is the other
aspect that i think is worth pointing
out and i think is interesting i've
talked about this on the show before
as as an indie and i'm sure lots of
other indies are looking at this exactly
the same way
when we see big companies doing
something over there
it's usually an interesting sign to
maybe go and look over there and what's
interesting here potentially
is if microsoft is you know is going to
have even more kind of of their own
in-house content coming out to game pass
that opportunity that's there right now
for indies uh to to have kind of a big
game pass splash that might start to
somewhat decrease in the same way as the
nintendo switch eventually decreased
once other what are the bigger companies
kind of start doing switch interesting
so
so you start looking around as indie
developer and going okay where's the
next gold rush where's the next
opportunity
and
we cycled all the way back to sony
almost with the kind of with the with
the the way that things were in the vita
era you know at the end of the feature i
think this is all public now hopefully
it is um with the at the end of like the
vita's life cycle there were like indies
were essentially kind of utilized as a
way of making interesting content come
out on the beta and you could definitely
point to the vita and go that the last
year of the vita's life cycle
in a serious kind of release way
was kind of pretty awesome because of
all these really interesting indie games
there was loads of opportunities and
that gave my generation of indie
developers this amazing headstart thomas
was alone that was the first console i
came out on was vitra i got to use the
vita to negotiate my way onto ps3 and
then from there built up something there
so it's
so weirdly like it does open up this
interesting opportunity of this if if if
that content starts to push over towards
xbox then there's maybe you know maybe
an opportunity within sony or with sony
to kind of find you know and to be clear
again similar to you i've not had any
conversations you're the first person
from sony i've talked to about this um
like but like i bet my pitch to them for
like an interesting kind of playstation
exclusive indie game if i were to make
one would be better received than it
would be six months ago and that's
that's uh there's a potential
interesting opportunity i wouldn't be
surprised if we started to see
some of some of that part of the
marketplace going over to sony and doing
interesting things and still on game
pass like obviously there's still an
amazing opportunity there and there's
still an amazing opportunity on switch
but these things work in cycles and it's
something we always have to pay
attention to as
you know people who have to like worry
about the rent
yeah i know the last time we spoke about
game pass extensively uh might have been
even a year ago and
um
obviously i i have game pass
again a lot of my colleagues have game
pass great service um
but i feel like
at the time
there was definitely a landscape of you
know i had seen you know people at
tinybuild for example had been like yeah
our game was very successful descenders
is the example that i use most often of
a game that i played on game pass that
found a lot of success on game pass and
has made more money by virtue of being
on game pass
where a lot of the conversation um in
the the the negative speculation on game
pass is that it devalues games that the
devs aren't making as much money that
doesn't tend to largely be
true it was almost like being on game
pass was a massive marketing push for a
lot of smaller studios look at what what
are the indie games we talked about in
the last year i would bet 80 percent of
them were getting past games
specifically for that reason unpacked as
a game like unpacking again uh
inscription because unpacking doesn't
unpacking doesn't build up the kind of
interest and audience
again within kind of quote-unquote
gamers who wouldn't necessarily buy an
indie game will absolutely play in game
pass and then because it's a charming
brilliant game that audience boyfriend
talks about it
my boyfriend was on game post did well
from it
there's like there's a there's an
enormous marketing push to it and then
and also these games are not going on
there for free like they are being paid
to be in there as well so there's also a
financial we you know that differs from
game to game and the audience isn't
aware of what that number is but like
it's not nothing having been in those
kind of conversations it's it's not
nothing and if you see a thing showing
up in one of these services they're not
doing it purely out of altruism there's
a financial incentive as well so my
question is do you think that you know
the more
studio acquisitions that microsoft gets
um they have a lot of studios now uh
that that could potentially have a
negative impact on
those individual indies because they are
now competing with call of duty for that
spotlight it could it could make us less
attractive like it's and that's not even
like a that's not negative on microsoft
like it's reasonable right if you've if
you've got a fridge full of food you're
not going to buy as much when you go to
the supermarket next time like you're
you know if you've got all of this stuff
at home why you know why will you
necessarily go out and be as aggressive
in wanting to acquire that content so i
don't i don't think it's i wouldn't i
wouldn't classify as this is terrible
for indies but no thank you
think by default it would create kind of
an ebb and flow in design which is
always the way like these things ebb and
flow like you know yeah there's there's
there it's happened like three or four
times in the time i've been like making
and selling stuff with my own company
like this is this just feels like maybe
the opportunity for another kind of area
to rise as kind of the indie
the indie gold mine the space where no
one's looking right now could be
something
that's it's having something i'm looking
for and i'm sure lots of other
developers are looking for what's that
next thing going to be really
interesting like until you mention i had
never really thought about how it for
sure was switch things were selling more
on switch than they had sold on previous
uh platforms by a dramatic margin i
remember i think it was shovel knight
found tremendous success um and then in
my career it was vita huh because there
was nothing and they they could because
they weren't getting any third party
support on vita so they reached out and
you had um
um
miami uk you had um gravity rush the us
doing it yeah you had all of all of the
indie stuff thomas was alone uh all of
this indie stuff that kind of used that
opportunity and did very well as a
result then a lot of us indies who were
on that kind of parlayed that into ps3
support uh yes you can have it on vita
but we also like to be on ps3 which at
the time was like kind of a rare enough
thing that that that meant something so
that was an open audience then the ps4
that first year on ps4 there weren't
many games coming out for ps4 so a lot
of indie games did very well in that
moment then as you say it moves to
switch
then it moves to game pass and now
what's next and it's not a zero-sum game
to be clear like our game still very
excel very well on switch for example
even though i'm saying that's like one
or two gold rushes behind but you know
you're trying to find where that new
blue ocean is that you can kind of jump
into um super interesting
yeah it makes sense there is like a
clear path where that just shifts and
and the good news is
you know even if this thing that we're
vaguely speculating about that maybe the
that gold rush isn't game pass but
indies anymore it doesn't mean it's
going anywhere it's not a net negative
for the zombies
yeah and and the players won't be left
behind like these once and once a
marketplace has been opened up we'll
still ship games there like it would
take a lot to get me to stop shipping a
game on switch like there's a massive
audience there who buy our stuff like
it's this is more about where the new
opportunity is opening up rather than
necessarily where
everywhere else is shutting down so yeah
it's definitely not zero sum but it's
but it that could that's that's just
kind of an immediate kind of reaction to
just kind of
knowing that microsoft now have access
to some big big stuff but i don't think
it's going to be i think a lot of people
are thinking this is going to be like
the next call of duty will be xbox
exclusive that's not how this will trade
i also don't think so though i do think
that's very interesting it's like what
will they make exclusive and what won't
they and i i feel like
you know people inside the industry seem
to be split on that people who who
uh i've spoken to over the last 24 hours
who work at different companies um
across the board seem to be disagreeing
on that so it's it's
you know as someone who has both i'm
good either way don't play a lot of cod
but uh it's going to be interesting to
see what the approach is because it's so
easy to say but call of duty multiplayer
is is such a juggernaut that why would
they not still want to make sure that
the playstation i'm interested in like
what are the answers you've had like
what's that what's the broad kind of
what's the range of opinions so i would
actually say um i've spoken to a lot of
people over the last 24 hours about this
i would say majority of people think
that and obviously this is all guesses
informed guesses
um that microsoft will not take
uh call of duty off of um
playstation uh and that potentially only
single player campaigns so that they may
have single player campaigns or uh dlc
content or extra content
um or potentially early um that was one
that that i was suggested to me more
than once that that it would be early
that you would get
cod on xbox um where they've had you
know those uh marketing deals with
playstation in the past
uh but they will not take the
multiplayer experience off of um
playstation overall because it would be
a bad idea for them financially to do
that um
that you still make the sales every time
somebody buys call of duty on
playstation you don't want to remove
that possibility especially when
that's on top of game pass because you
know that a lot of playstation players
could be subscribed to game pass why
would you remove that sale it seems like
an odd choice um it and also a fan you
create today could be someone you
migrate over later that's a lot of i
think the the playstation games on pc
kind of conversation as well of like it
doesn't necessarily you don't
necessarily just make money from a
franchise at this moment you make money
from a franchise over the lifetime of
the audience who's interested in so you
can kind of
yeah there's you you want those on-ramps
still i think well one interesting
suggestion speaking of the on-ramps that
i saw was somebody said that they think
that um
that you'll be able to play call of duty
on playstation but that you will inside
of the game
get literal ads for uh game pass that
you'll get like your little blip where
they usually give you like here's what's
happening this season you'll get get
this early on game pass and you'll see
an xbox logo inside of a game that
you're playing on playstation and they
were like i'm positive that's what
they'll do they'll advertise game pass
on playstation like interesting that's
interesting so so that's actually a
brilliant example of exactly what i was
talking about earlier about the the
trickle-down of these kind of things so
there are massively
obviously lots of rules on all consoles
about not mentioning other consoles or
other games offerings on other consoles
in your game
that is an absolute kind of
no one can do this that's terrible don't
do that yeah you will if the if a logo
or a button prompt that is specific to a
platform other than the one that you're
on is in your game you are in a lot of
trouble yeah um
and not in a serious way but like no
that's it's not a law but they'd be like
broken
but like if a company is powerful in
this moment as the company making call
of duty
changes that rule or gets an exemption
from that rule that can open up the door
so that i can have you know
when i release game x on
on uh
let's say switch to make it unspecific
to this this specific uh conflict if i
release a game on switch
you know called game x but i want to
promote game y and the game y is a pc
exclusive for the time being
that maybe opens a door to me having
like a little banner ad or something in
my indie game that kind of can push my
audience because you'd be amazed like
how often i'll see a conversation around
one of our games
uh you know
and if our if another game of ours isn't
released on that platform they will not
have heard of it and they'll their
friends will be saying oh have you tried
this other game that bethel's made and
because it's not on their platform no
i've never played it and i probably
won't because it's not my platform so
there's a real opportunity there again
like
once someone powerful who brings a lot
of power of money to a platform wants to
do something that can open up an
opportunity for the rest of us to kind
of
also do that thing so that's an
interesting yeah i only saw one one
person say that but the person who said
that i don't think everybody knows
the person who said that um was adamant
about it but it was only one um yeah
it's been a lot of different takes and
of course we you know we are speculating
just as much as everybody else is about
this and and the speculation
people can be as adamant as they like
about some of them like we don't know
like you you truly don't know and uh as
i said at the start of it i have
genuinely no inside track on this and
usually we do usually we've heard
something or like this i have no
knowledge or information about no i had
absolutely no idea um
and of course
you know part of the conversation of
that is that minecraft is really what
throws it out the window is like
microsoft bought mojang
and that's still on all platforms um
because obviously that was beneficial to
them so yeah we don't know what they're
gonna do um be interesting to see
uh
but you touched on this a little bit
earlier so let me circle back to it um
what do you feel like the positives are
from your perspective from like an
industry perspective of this like
outside of talking about you know
potentially
you know creating a different kind of
competitivity like what are your gut
reaction positives of this kind of
acquisition
positive and again the people
shout out to the people we hope you get
treated shout out to the people
hopefully there will be tree beds i
honestly i think that's that is
definitely the best
possible positive hopefully if
i think there's enough incentive on a
lot enough people who need that to
happen that that will happen so that's
absolutely um the uh
i guess the other positives of it
honestly acquisitions in general are
it's in a way it's good because they
they do tend to remind people with money
that they can just buy companies like
sometimes i think that's useful we're
definitely in a period right now
where a lot of acquisitions are
happening like there's there's there's
several players like just buying up lots
and lots of stuff to the extent that i
don't think i've started a call
with uh with any business
partner or or colleague in a different
company in the last month without them
making a joke of so have you been bought
by x yet
um because there are like two or three
people who are buying everything and a
lot of it's take two's doing it too and
nobody's mentioning it take two just
sportszinger
yeah and it's and it's so that there's
you know that's a potential benefit to
you know
the individuals who own companies
obviously um but to the industry in
general i i
i think i'm trying to think of another
positive i
it's
it really is a positive i think just two
people directly involved more than
anyone and i don't know if there's a
generalized positive outcome to one big
company buying another big company uh
beyond the kind of nuance that we're
talking about like maybe it opens up
some opportunities it shakes things up
anything that shakes up the industry is
usually good for
bottom feeders like me like
it's rats do very well straight after
fires
um so it makes sense because yeah thank
you for funny
you did yes probably yeah it's probably
not great but yeah i think it makes
sense how about you can you can you see
positives beyond what we've discussed um
again my go-to is is people uh i also
think that you know i
again speaking as a player
um i hope that there's not something
that i'm forgetting um as i am want to
do with the amount of video games that i
play but i feel like i haven't loved
any actor blizzard games um recently
uh
there hasn't been anything that's come
out that i have i have
you know really gravitated towards in a
while um and i
sort of
in my head i'm like it's a change so
potentially you know they they
uh change the way they release games
they change their approach to some games
um
it just means that we could be getting
in theory
just with a different leadership
structure you know potentially a
different level of quality or a
different approach or or um one thing
that i like about the game pass model
is shorter games
so
uh across the board i don't want that i
i don't want you know my big blockbuster
titles um
i don't want fable to be short for
example whenever um they're really sad i
don't want that to be a short game but
if you could give me like i love the
battlefield one campaign um of course
battlefield's still ea but i love that
campaign of these like little vignette
war stories and i was like well if you
would do that with call of duty i'd be
more inclined to play it and i do think
the call of duty campaigns are quite
good but i'm not uh inclined to invest
all my time in them every year um when
you know they can be so systematically
similar so to me it's like it's it's the
same same vein uh from a very different
perspective from a player perspective is
like we could get different games out of
this we could get some smaller game pass
releases things more often things are a
little bit more interesting and
different
where i feel like i've not been
tremendously interested in a lot of
activision blizzard um properties
recently i'm trying to think of like
what outside of
i'm doing my usual google of who owns
psyops the winegate conspiracy now
because that is the ip that i will one
day
get hold of and make more of
um
because whenever so whenever a big ip
purchase happens like you even thought
that was sakura i was like is that where
we get sakura 2 but they don't own
fromsoft so there's no
indication there there's a chance they
own the ice so often the publisher will
own the ip of a game they publish even
if a different developer made it right
but i assume in from software's case
that's so i would think that they i
would think that that activision owns
the ip of sakura i'm sure we could look
this up and just aren't i would think
that they do unless microsoft does but
it's not like i would want sakura 2
unless fromsoft was making it so that
doesn't
really interest me necessarily like if
there's no guarantee that it would be a
fromsoft game then
i don't really want it
if you own the psyops the mindgate
conspiracy ip uh i'd like to hit you up
hit me up i'm i'm on it
you probably i doubt psyops probably
before you started playing games right
oh yeah but i do know silence i've never
yeah played silence
i need that i i was it is the yeah it's
a it's a solid 6 out of 10 game but i
would love it's my one i think every
developer has like one ip that like
floats around in the background that
they would love to get i um obviously i
can't talk about ip acquisition um but
if there was ever a universe
in which i was just i was thinking about
this that you know the more that i do my
job the more that i realize how how much
i love horror games i'm always like what
if it was scary
um i'd die to work on silent hill
like
if there was a new silent hill and i
could work on that
well let's get konami you and me we're
going together we'll get we'll buy
comments the good shake up mel you know
everybody's up for grabs
we'll put a thousand dollars together
and we'll buy connell play watch list so
he's going to purchase konami that's
we're announcing it on the show right
now that's that's just you wait we're
working on it
i'm trying to look at
a list of activision recent releases so
in the last 12 months it's been call of
duty warzone modern warfare 2
tony hawk
good stuff sakura shadow state twice
crash bandicoot so this is not lost one
that's recent um crash bandicoot 4 it's
about time which i really liked
crash bandicoot's interesting that's
that's microsoft getting another
child-friendly franchise and also
another mascot that was previously tied
to a separate platform obviously it
happened with bands spyro as well that's
with activation yeah
uh banjo kazooie obviously it happened
forever ago but of course but less
well-known among modern games for sure
yeah um i don't know the crash and spyro
are either though they are
they are necessary
from skylanders because i remember i was
which is choice for bob
i worked around spyro and crash
bandicoot kind of earlier in my career
and like back then nobody cared but yes
skylanders there's because they have the
best if you show a picture
yeah if you show spyro to a kid or a
crash bandicoot they will know what that
that's interesting yeah um so that's
that's potentially an interesting idea
yeah taking those mascots microsoft's
super interesting and i i mean i had a
thought um with with all of these too
that it's like you know we always talk
about what would the microsoft version
of smash be
um it's like you could you could they
had they stopped making skylanders um i
used to have to review skylanders for
ign so i played a lot of skylanders in
my time you were the ones that like did
mouth feel i remember that was the big
thing with amiibos and with skylanders
was that did you ever have your mouth
feel review of those things no
that was a big thing was i swear now i
sound like a crazy the last one that i
did with skyline is imaginative which i
think was the last skylanders and it was
really funny because i didn't give it a
great review score there's been
skylanders games that i really liked i
didn't like imaginative as much and i
had so many parents come get mad at me
they were parents like my kid loves this
game why did you give it i don't know a
seven or whatever i gave it
yeah it was very funny that was that was
twenty now those kids have grown up to
flame you for every other video exactly
yeah full full cycle um i'm not sure
about mouth feel though what are you
what are you referring to no i like
someone in the comments will know what
i'm talking about but everyone else will
think i'm just a crazy crazy
there was i think was it polygon maybe
it was polygon someone did a bunch of
reviews of like amiibo and skylanders
type in amiibo mouth feel i swear i'm
not making this up
they would review them based on how they
felt put in your mouth
what that that okay i swear this is real
listen i
can't find it but i did find a
destructoid article that was amiibo as
butt plugs ranked
that is a different that is that is
that is as close to the opposite of what
i'm talking about
it could be i don't doubt that some
degenerate has it's probably polygon
some degeneration
um
but griffin's it was griffin mcelroy oh
he did a twitter thread that makes sense
no he knows no he wrote it video
and they were like two three four minute
reviews of amiibos based on what they
felt like
my god
doing the lord's work i've so vindicated
that that's real they didn't have some
kind of weird fever dream at some point
um so the last one on the list to round
it out was call of duty vanguard from
sledgehammer obviously so that's
everything that they've released since
2020 which isn't a tremendous amount of
video games um what's interesting is the
number of excellent teams though oh so
like call of duty people kind of breeze
over now but it's infinity ward like you
said raven you've got
raven sledgehammer treyarch each of
those is a and treyarch all four of
those are like world-class first persons
do something else
the thing that's appealing about that is
that maybe if they aren't under
activision as it is structurally right
now is that maybe we move one of them
over to another franchise obviously we
had um all x call of duty devs came
together to create titanfall which is
still a shooter but i think that
titanfall 2 is like one of the best fps
campaigns we've ever had um and they've
made something very different maybe this
allows for it's the best valve game
valve never totally um maybe this allows
for less of that like three year
structure that is also you know known to
burn people out as well like call of
duty sounds i was playing raven games
when i was a teenager like raven are
like i don't know what they do on call
of duty i know they work on most of them
so they started working with id didn't
they that's how raven started i think it
was that they started working out um
or it was something to do with john
romero
yeah there's a lot of early
software i played a lot yeah soldier of
fortune star wars jedi knight um
wolfenstein like they did lots of
lots of yeah heretic hexan like just
1990 discovered by john romero
co-founder of id who collaborated with
raven to make uh games using their game
engine beginning with shadowcaster so
then they started making games with id
and then were bought out in
1997 by activision but ra they so what
do they
they work on a lot of call of duties but
not by themselves i think they're i
think their platform size i think
they're basically like maintaining the
core framework kind of debugging i'm
just looking at the work oh they made
call of duty
the face of their considered the face of
maintaining updating and debugging the
game so yeah they're they're like
support studios well recognized as great
yeah tech skills interesting um
but i but yeah so there's a lot there's
a lot of uh institutional awareness
there and a lot of it's been thrown at
one specific problem call of duty they
don't take a year to make each call of
duty game there are this stagger you
know this obviously i'm talking past you
to the audience but like it is it's like
ubisoft it's they're making they're
rolling these big projects
so yeah like you say like call of duty
goes down to one a year or one game
that's maintained long term you know and
doesn't have to have a yearly iteration
each time then suddenly some interesting
studios kind of free up to potentially
do completely new stuff yeah
which could totally happen
which makes sense given microsoft's kind
of american focus
um that you would you know first person
shooter and action games in general are
still like the the quintessential
american genre so yeah did they acquire
any sports
they did activision has
with so many
[Music]
i know they generally activision are one
of the publishers that's moved away from
licensing in
general um
i mean i could be mr memory
away from the sports stuff i'm just
trying to find it for you in any case um
a lot of uh a lot of studios there and
and you know i i think like like
to answer your question of what are the
positives to me as a player it is
diversifying um
[Music]
what
activision puts out um and maybe getting
more things i think is is neat uh did
you also see the the thing about bobby
kotek trying to buy
pc gamer qatar
pc gamer
it's such a that's such a villainous
1940s superman villain oh my god we will
buy the press so they will like us
it's actually i saw someone i saw a
journalist right and it was it's very
true of like
if you ever wanted proof that game
journalism actually does matter
like there's your example right that
actually it's true because for someone
in his unless he is just very petty
which is entirely possible like
uh allegedly um
the there is there then
there must be a stock impact for that to
be something that would be important
yeah kind of to to him um so yeah so so
game journalism matters like that's
that's an empirical proof of that as a
concept
keep telling publishers when they do
things that you don't like that's that's
what i i would take away from that it
means that you should you should keep
what keep it up free a free press is
essential to
any republic in my opinion
um and even some aging old empires
[Laughter]
um we're already at an hour is there
anything that we haven't really covered
here probably a list of things i thought
were interesting did we get through all
of that did you i said i did you didn't
read it's fine i don't read things you
sent me
no i understand i wouldn't
um
marketplace
consolidation
specific reason microsoft might choose
to buy right now our guess was to do
with yeah that that potentially being
more valuable right now it was a bargain
for us
game parties the stock price being that
low
game pass push but also like that was a
good moment for them to buy it from a
stock perspective like they got a good
deal yeah
um
definitely interesting
didn't see it coming i'm glad that i'm
not alone but like you said like usually
you hear a whisper usually usually you
know something i would have heard at the
game awards someone would have said
something
but not a yeah the game awards would
have been that would have been the
moment right few people having some
drinks you'd have heard something
nothing
nothing i have friends at uh at
activision in australia uh someone i was
talking to um just the other day
and
uh i was like big morning for you huh
and she was like i had no idea so she
woke up again on australian time so it's
delayed um just like oh
okay so my guess is that they they
kept it pretty low-key um oh my god i
just saw because of my recent searches
that danganronpa is on game pass right
now you should play dank and romp
everybody go play danganronpa on game
pause oh my god danganronpa is
um i mean do you like do you like
persona it's not the better this is not
played it's okay so it's that like in
those are the fans generally of both of
those franchises danganronpa is
is absolutely a graphic novel it's a lot
of reading but is batshit that's fine
nuts and a lot of fun
i know i know the only the main thing i
know about persona is that a lot of
people who are fans of me are also fans
of persona so i probably would like it
like that's usually that's actually a
way i get recommendations is seeing what
yeah i mean personas vibes yeah personas
i know my games are that's fine yeah
it's okay yeah so like i don't know
about i don't know if they would like
because your games are so mid like would
you even compare the two it's weird to
have them in the same conversation i
mean the games you like are nothing like
this
no that's just oh you know
it's like with it's like how i had to
watch one episode of my little pony
because i noticed everyone who tweets
positively about thomas was alone had a
my little pony avatar for a while so i
was like probably i'd like my little
pony then that's funny um i mean yeah
persona is fantastic it's it's a
heartfelt very i think one of the
persona 5 is one of the most stylish
games ever made um rpg whereas dank and
romper is also very stylish very good
storytelling yeah it's about characters
in heart and i feel like you've got some
of that going on
not anymore i've had my heart broken by
how cruel you've been to me in the last
five minutes it's gonna cut you down a
peg sometimes you know it's a money bag
it's going to be my place yeah i
understand yeah i'm doing a service it's
for the greater good
um all right yeah obviously very
impromptu recorded episode uh that sadly
we do not have a troy or an austin for
because we really just did decide to do
this an hour before doing it apologies
for that everybody but this has been
play watch listen i'm alana i'm a video
game writer and that is mike bithell he
is a video game director we will see you
guys next week